in Yemen's brutal war is the civilians
who are bearing the brunt thousands have
died millions on the brink of starvation
I think the dominant cause has been the
saudi-led coalition the fact that it
keeps bombing civilians and civilian
infrastructure despite having the best
weaponry money can buy Saudi Arabian the
United Arab Emirates are both fighting
in Yemen and it's here at this arms fan
Abu Dhabi that they're shopping for the
latest lethal technology both are among
the German arms industry's top clients
but Berlin has repeatedly denied any
knowledge of german-made arms employed
in Yemen I'm not aware of it we have in
our coalition agreement let down some
very restrictive rules for further
export of military weapons to parties
immediately and directly involved in the
German conflict that is now being
implemented I have not had any news
about it so far Germany prides itself on
these strict arms export guidelines
which banned the sale of weapons to
countries involved in armed conflict
but DW and its investigative partners
report minion Stan magazine lighthouse
reports & Belling cut trawled loads of
videos photos and satellite images and
found evidence that German weapons sold
to the Emirates and Saudi Arabia are in
fact being used in the Yemen war in the
air at sea and on land this is a German
made warship in the port of Makkah and
Yemen it's one of two minesweepers sold
to the Emirates satellite images
repeatedly showed German made vessels in
the Eritrean port of uh SAP hisab is a
main base for the naval blockade of
Yemen which has led to widespread
starvation this is a convoy of foreign
mercenaries in Yemen fighting for the
Emirates in the convoy a German built
weapon station mounted on armored
vehicles these fighters are dancing
around the wreckage of a Saudi Arabian
tornado combat jet which crashed in
Yemen tornadoes have many German
components women's that exported to
Saudi and Emirates that makes a big
effects against Yemenis is that it is
the tools of Saudi and Emirates to kill
Yemenis so I'm calling West all the
Australian countries to stop selling
weapons to Saudi and Aamir's back at the
defence fair the Emiratis signed weapons
deals worth more than five billion
dollars many of them with Western
companies and those arms too could end
up in Yemen's brutal conflict so let's
get reaction to this story we are joined
now by Juergen heart to foreign policy
spokesperson for the conservative
cdu/csu Parliamentary Group in the
Bundestag welcome to the program and
thanks for joining us and I'd like to
begin by asking you I mean we see the
evidence there presented by DW news that
that German made arms are being used in
the war in Yemen it seems as if the
German government arms export guidelines
have failed in this case right I think
this case needs to be investigated
deeply every state that gets weapons
from Germany was
of the government has to sign and
confirm that these weapons remain in the
state where they are delivered to and if
probably one state misses to to fulfill
those obligations as might have be
consequences for future delivery of
weapons but concerning the situation in
Yemen I would remind us all that there
is a legitimate Yemeni tech government
that is fighting against insurgents
terrorists sponsored by Iran against the
legitimate government of Yemen and that
there is a coalition of some states that
is allowed and asked by the Yemeni
government to help them to fight against
this terrorists and therefore a total
ban on all activity in that war might
not be helpful to solve so solution what
we see is that for example Saudi Arabia
is harming international war a law on
war because Arabia attend to their
activities let's talk about Saudi Arabia
because I mean we know I and I want to
ask you specifically because Germany
imposed an arms embargo on Saudi Arabia
after the alleged murder of the
journalist Jim alcohol G in the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul we understand it's
due to expire in about a week does the
government plan to renew the ban from my
point of view we should think about that
we continue to do that what we agreed on
in the coalition at the beginning of
last year we decided not to delivery
deliver weapons to power up two states
that are active in the civil war in
Yemen but with some exclusions we say
that some petrol petrol boats smaller
boats lightly armed and weapons built in
Germany can be delivered again to the
audio abya because they are not able to
be a player role in that Yemen conflict
and from my point of view we should
think about to come back to that strict
but in this case open regulatory and
that we agreed under the Coalition in
March last year just a few days ago you
criticize the grand coalition partners
this
Democrats for what you called a
restrictive stance on arms export
policies do you stand by that or you
know are you are you rethinking it now
that you've been confronted with this
information yeah
we have the most tricked export regime
on weapons all over Europe but we need a
good equipment for our Bundeswehr we
want to have the best equipment for the
Bundeswehr and we cannot deliver and
produce and develop that by us own
because the the numbers of tools we need
art of you
therefore we need cooperation in in
armament industry and our partners for
example like France expect that we agree
on how we handle potentially export
demand on those goods in case that we we
develop that together we built that
together we bring that in theory and
others ask to have that and I think it's
good to have an agreement between the
governments before we start that
cooperation about how we handle this
export amount and not only to take of
that topic and the end of the treaty
this might harm our relations to others
and for my point of view we have to face
the fact that maybe sometimes others for
example like France
asked us to probably be more moderate in
this field and I think concerning our
moralistic standpoint we can do more for
peace and word if we convince others to
follow their most restrictive regulation
in Germany then to do all by their own
without Germany German free equipment of
the German Bundeswehr I think it's not
possible to have that Jurgen heart
foreign policy spokesperson for the
conservative cdu/csu parliamentary group
in the Bundestag thank you
you